hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
we are now past the midpoint of season X
of four night battle royale the island
continues to evolve and change leaving
us with clues to uncover so let's go
over everything week six has to offer
Oh also think about subscribing please
I'd really like to reach 1 million
subscribers in 2019 and you have the
power to make that happen in return I
will show you my fog Lea face do we have
a deal
this week in season X we have another
movie crossover the return of Kevin the
cube and some important news about HUD
watch so would you kindly use a damaru
in the font I shop take 10 minutes away
from the real world prepare yourself for
terrible jokes and let's go through all
the map changes this week we knew an
entire week in advance about what was
going on this week our Lord and Savior
Kevin the cube is back his purple
highness is currently bench-pressing an
island in the sky which so happens to be
the greatest landing spot in Fortnight
history the motel we thought it was gone
forever when the block decided to set up
shop there but it's ok the motel the
hotel the Holiday Inn will be a hot drop
for the rest of the season I'm really
tempted to drop 100 times here do you
think Luke the notable will let me maybe
we should ask him the motel has changed
from the old G spot and is now fused
with the loot lake house and a few other
items from across the map this could be
a sign of where the island will fly to
trees from the desert loads of loot lake
items and a lonely Lodge site too even
the bones of the Loch Ness monster have
returned but there's a travesty to
report
sadly in all the commotion a real-life
diploid oculus has lost its life our
leader ali-a has a few words to say is
sign that is the question we're gonna be
taking a look at today I need an
intervention I've got to stop doing
these jokes about ali-a he's gonna find
out where I live he's a millionaire he
can hire a hitman I'm so sorry Alistair
please don't kill me
[Music]
back over to our Kevin he works just
like he did in the past
he's bouncy like your mum he was sorry
he's bouncing just like a trampoline and
the greatest trolling mechanic returns
shoot the cube and Kevin will lash out
at the closest person to it back when he
rolled around the map all those seasons
ago it was my favorite thing to do okay
it's time to get real it's time for I'm
delighted to say the hutt watch goes on
no improvements this week but it's still
here I thought it was going to be
smashed to smithereens
but we do have a real problem to discuss
if you remember when hot watch started
it was because Kevin wanted to smash
through everything and the og hood was
the first thing on his list I hate to
say this but this could be the last week
of hot watch in seven days that Hut may
be gone forever so do you know what
we're gonna turn this frown upside down
we are going to have a competition
you've heard of alpha harambe well now
it's time for bottle flips for hot watch
get your butt over to hot watch and flip
a bottle then upload it to youtube the
most cinematic and awesome bottle flips
will be added to this section next week
also let me know what kind of prize you
think the winner should get later this
week another crossover will take place
if you want that to be a surprise please
skip ahead to this timecode have they
gone they've gone they've gone let's
crack on fortnight cross it chapter 2
for those that don't know what night is
a game about bringing families together
to have a fun and fabulous time and it
is a series of horror films to scare the
bejesus out of you the perfect crossover
material the greatest fortnight Lika I
know for Tori has found an art asset of
a balloon coming this month in the films
there's a clown called penny wise who
uses a red balloon to draw children into
his lair sounds lovely doesn't it and to
confirm this
check out this laughter fire off be
prepared for incoming nightmare fuel
alright I'm officially scared of clowns
right now let's move on over at dusty
Depot the home of the visitor each week
he's been upgrading and updating the
decor and the beacons he creates they
only seem to be subtle changes but every
week they do take place this week the
part of the mech which is being scanned
has changed again
what the heck could this represent is
the visitor using the mech tech to
upgrade the beacons to perfect it
certainly looks that way
and speaking of perfecting beacons the
visitor has successfully brought back
Kevin
albeit a mixed up version of him but the
important thing here is that the farm
fatal fields remains in one piece it's
the first time he's managed that so
there's hope for hot watch yet and also
this gives us insight into the visitors
plan I'll add that to this week's story
other smaller updates to the map in the
last few weeks include the no dancing
signs we've all become used to over the
last few seasons they're everywhere
even the villains lair has one and the
junkyard 2 also over at the ice-cream
man's house on the hill or granny's
house or whatever the heck you call it
another challenge houses visit season
four again and all the movie posters
from the hero vs. villains film great to
reminisce but this should feed back into
the return of risky reels which I went
over to look at and it's still
completely the same over by sunny steps
another returning challenge is the
dance-off which can be found over at
frosty flights Oh in fact there is one
last thing that I almost missed have you
been keeping an eye on the Rif table
over at loot Lake it's still cracking
it's still going to explode so if we
compare all the footage we've got so far
it continues to grow it's going to
explode at some point will it take the
entire island with it I hope so
I need a new island I may be wrong but
everything else on the island looks
untouched but if I've missed something
please let me know in the comments I
think the next update which coincides
with Pandora leaving will have plenty
more updates to go through oh there is a
little update to the prefabs in creative
you notice what's been added it's the
prison oh gee players will know it well
once upon a time it was found in wailing
woods
it was then destroyed by a meteor blast
and then completely taken away when the
desert arrived could this give us a hint
about next week's update and the other
prefab which has been added is none
other than flush Factory the original
flush Factory and oh there's another one
which is starting to grow in the snowy
area but at the moment nothing to
progress there
so are these prefabs hinting at
something or are they more red herrings
let me know your thoughts where do you
think the next beacon will be switched
on so to finish let's have another crack
at a story theory a narrative version of
events leading up to next season
this week it's all about Armageddon the
fortnight apocalypse and our escape to a
new Island black bass check dramatic
music check let's do this
the first fortnight event saw a rocket
leave our world never to return again
but little did we know at the time that
rocket was both the start and the end of
this fortnight Island the first and last
moment we would experience the Alpha and
the Omega witnessing the first rocket
blasts into space it became apparent
something malfunctioned this was not
what was intended the intergalactic
space rocket was unable to pass through
the dome which imprisons the island and
instead opened up wormholes to other
dimensions and suddenly he was gone
time went on we all moved forward and
forgot about the visitor but then seized
an X arrived and the visitors plan is
now back on track during his time away
in other worlds he had been hard at work
learning the layout of time and mapping
every dimension and every possible
outcome following the meteor hitting
it's now clear he's here now to take us
to one of those other worlds the only
problem is the rocket is lost in time
our hero has two options to build a new
rocket but that would take too long or
perfect the rift beacons to bring back
the original rocket from all those
seasons ago he gets to work using code a
damaru in the foreign hai shop until the
rift beacons are ready over the course
of season X he trials the rift beacons
around the island but now he's perfected
it he takes it over to the old villains
lair which is now dilapidated and guess
what the beacon worked the rocket
returns we are all saved season X ends
and season one begins on a brand-new
Island in a different diamond
[Music]
boom what do you think about that theory
I'm sure you'll agree the major part of
that story was using cold atom arrow in
the font night shop yeah sorry about
that I do like this theory though as a
new island to explore would be great and
calling it season one again would stop
the number getting ridiculously high
season 11 sounds ancient to me what do
you think anyway like always let me know
your theories in the comments I'll grab
me over on Twitter the links in the
description and I will add your theories
to next week's attempt so that was
season x week 6 thank you to those who
used my code in the pot night shop it
really does make a difference
you are leggins to me so hopefully you
can spot your name here do me a favor
guys book me in for next week and we'll
do this all over again I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
see you soon
[Music]